[Musique]
donc il répondait bon s'habille comme
mal assure c'est à peu près le look
c'est un genou à nouveau un génie plus
en moi venant de cherbourg en normandie
là où je vois pas du tout de métro
d'ailleurs vers quoi que ce soit on a
juste quelques bus qui desservent
évidemment les villes mais en dehors
c'est l'écart assez compliqué pour le
prendre à avoir deux minutes d'attenté
entre les deux c'est top mais votre elle
en pense quoi
mon frère merci à hall
qu'est ce que tu penses qu est ce que
vous pensez des transports en commun
parisiens ce que je pense de houla
alors très sincèrement je me déplace
surtout à pied surtout là quand il fait
beau comme ça et n'ont en général c'est
un peu crade quand même et sa base et
hashtag fin de journée c'est compliqué
j'ai cliqué je suis un peu raide un peu
oui je suis un peu raide hashtag grosse
crise
et hier pour aller à sacré coeur on a
pris une fois le bus et le but c'était
bien oui il était très gentil les
conducteurs parce qu'on savait pas trop
où de cendres
très à l'aise il nous a dit attendez au
moment où ils nous appellent le 19 des
sondés cela ils en pensent quoi bon quoi
autre frère j'ai pas de frère première
nouvelle par votre nom c'est pas mon
truc mon père désolé abbas bon autant
pour je croyais être le cas du piston à
l'école ensemble
j'ai en fait elle est petite sont à
l'école ensemble sont les des parents
d'élèves au cédez votre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]